figures were released with the latest
numbers of covert
spread let's talk to thomas moore who
can bring us more
thomas yeah these are the the latest
statistics from the nhs test and trace
system
and they show that in the week up to the
16th of september there were 19
278 people who were testing
positive that's three times as many as
at the end of august and just underlines
the explosive
growth of the coronavirus as we
flipped over the calendar into september
really did
go up very sharply indeed and that's
also reflected in the
the proportion of people who are testing
positive
now that's also going up and it just
reflects that this is
a real increase in the virus it's not an
artifact of testing which is what many
scientists have been saying over the
summer
this is something that really is
something to be concerned about
the numbers also show that nhs test and
trace is still struggling to keep up
with demand
and perhaps the most alarming figure on
that is that
uh in that week only 28
of in-person test results were returned
in 24 hours and speed is everything
when you're trying to stay ahead of the
virus the week before
it was 33 so it's decreasing that really
is
in trouble and another measure of just
how much uh it is in trouble the
proportion of people
um uh who were reached through the
contact racing that's the second part if
you like if you
you need to find out who has been in in
contact with these positive cases
uh well that was uh just under uh
uh 77.7 point 77.7 percent
uh that's down from 84 the week before
so this
backlog of cases uh in laboratories is
beginning to have an
impact on the whole system and that will
mean that fewer contacts are able to be
reached
in time to make sure they're properly
quarantining
and reducing the risk to us all